What's up everybody? Welcome to another business Q&A while I play League of Legends.
I'm excited to be here. Live stream number two out of nine of the day.
Cheering on the Toronto Blue Jays. That kind of rhymes. I'm pumped.
I've got my usual co-host Rishi Cut TV. Welcome aboard.
Happy to be here. Happy Thursday Believe Nation.
People want to know what's in the cup.
Oh, yes. Well, today I have.
I don't know if you guys tried the s'mores flavored Dunkin Donuts coffee,
but I'm drinking that right now. Cup of s'mores, which I will say it's not.
I don't think I'll ever buy it again. It's not my favorite, but it's OK.
And and healing a cup of grateful for all the people that are in the chat today.
Got a lot of returning chatter in the live chat today.
So fun time. I love it. We don't have Dunkin Donuts in Canada, so we can't try the s'mores.
It's too bad. Oh, I didn't realize that. Yeah.
Yeah, it's everywhere in the U.S., but we don't have it here.
I don't know why it's one of the only that usually the brands come north.
But I remember the sizes being insane. I went to New York City and got a large Coke or something.
And the large is just off the charts large. That would be like a double extra large or something.
Canadian size Dunkin Donuts. Cool.
Well, let's see who's in the live chat. Give some shout outs. We got Soul Forged.
Twenty four fifty three coming back. We got Rishi.
We got Rise Online. Zeno is back in the house. Last minute, Louie.
Three in a row. Woo. Woo hoo. Louie, you got to join us. Louie is a league player, too.
Come on, Louie. You got to join us next time. And what else?
The Master 57, whoever the master is. Oh, apparently the s'mores from Starbucks.
I did not know that. I got to check that out. Oh, yeah.
I didn't try the Starbucks one. Just the Dunkin one. Zeno's asking any experiments today.
We're doing we're doing the same. We're doing the same thing as yesterday, I think.
We're going to try to pull out a victory. Louie, why not play Ivern today?
Because Timo is the best. Because Timo is where it's at, friends. Timo for days.
Yeah. I got the Timo love happening.
Cool. Well, we're setting up a game and let's let's get into some questions.
What do we have first? OK, great.
I hope you all are excited in that chat. Let me know in that chat how excited you guys are for today and the question.
All right. So first question comes from Jacob.
And yesterday, actually, we had some young young entrepreneurs writing in.
So we're kind of continuing that. Jacob's 14 years old and he is first just saying thank you because he says that you commented on.
He made a comment on one of your videos a while back and you replied that he said, thank you for acknowledging my comment.
Which I just wanted to point that out because that's part of the love of Believe Nation and Evan is that he'll always acknowledge your comment.
And my friends and I are starting a clothing line in hopes that someday our clothing line will be a worldwide designer brand.
We are currently working on some products, but because of our age, we're not able to get a license until three to four years from now.
Also, because we are living on our money, it's hard to get supplies that we need for clothes.
And then because we're so limited in money. Oh, no, that's pretty much it.
So he's basically 14 year old. His friend is 15 and they want to start a clothing line.
And they don't have any money or they have limited money and they just wanted to kind of know how can they what tips and advice do you have for them to get past these hurdles.
And he said, thank you for your time.
Love it.
So, yeah, I love that. I just love that these 14 year old 15 year old entrepreneurs are ambitious and they're really proactively reaching out for help.
I think that's super cool.
And I know there are a couple, two that I know of, but maybe even more.
Videos on Evan's channel that address exactly this question. How do you start a clothing line with, you know, little experience, no experience and then no money.
So definitely make sure you check those videos out by just searching on YouTube, because they'll definitely pop up.
And I just love one of the things that I remember on that video was, you know, Evan, you're always talking about modeling the masters.
And so whether you're 14 or 44, you know, it's helpful to find out who are other clothing designers, fashion designers that you look up to and how did they do it?
How did they start from nothing and build something? Because I think that you can learn a lot.
So there are probably even several on Evan's channel as well that talk about their success and kind of their stories.
And I think that's a really cool way to get mentored by just, you know, finding out what other people have done.
And another thing, too, I think with fashion is just being able to get feedback right away from people about your design.
So you may not have the money to go out and buy a whole bunch of T-shirts and do anything on a large scale.
But why don't you try making maybe a shirt for a friend or a few shirts for your friends or maybe even shirts for, you know, anyone in your life, your teachers.
And just kind of get feedback. And it's a way that you can, I think, right away start getting out there, start testing.
And you could even start part time, you know, if you're busy with school and but you do need money.
You know, what about a weekend job where you find a way to, you know, generate some kind of income?
So, yeah, those are my thoughts. But definitely check out those videos. There's a lot of good information there.
There's a couple things that come to mind with this question.
Okay.
One, I, you know, I just, I think back and wish that when I was 12 years old and hustling my baseball cards that there was this kind of format.
If there was someone to reach out to and ask questions to, man, I would be all over it.
And so I love it. I love that the young entrepreneurs are, you know, are hitting it up, asking questions, watching videos.
Guys, there's no excuse. Like, you have, all of you, all of you, you have the information here.
Not just my channel, just YouTube, the Internet, use it. I'm jealous. I'm jealous.
The second part was about comments and he was grateful that I replied to one of his comments.
I think it's really important for anybody building a community. I mean, anybody building a business, right?
You want to respond to your customers, your leads, people who write in.
But especially people who build a community, there's this stigma about, you know, communities are, you know, YouTube is a place of trolls.
It's all negative. Even this, when we went to Twitch, you know, a lot of people said, don't go to Twitch.
You're going to get a lot of haters in the comments. You know, it's just all negative there.
And look at our live Twitch chat. You know, it's always positive. And YouTube is almost always positive.
And yes, you know, we get some trolls and some haters and some negative people.
But I think it's because of the personal commitment. Like, I think we've had positivity and success in the community and all the videos that I put out at the start because I'm a positive person and I was involved in it.
Right? And then I brought on people to work with me who are positive people as well.
And we try to respond to every single comment, whether it's me or someone on my team, and keep that positive flow going.
And so if you are creating something and you're trying to build a community up and you're worried about negative comments and people being bullies and trolls.
If you are involved from day one and spreading a positive message, then you're going to get positive people.
And, you know, we might have the most positive community on YouTube, at least one of the most positive communities that I've seen on YouTube.
And now we're just doing it all over again on Twitch. You know, it just keeps happening.
And so if you are involved and spreading that positive vibe, you're going to get positive people watching.
And the people who are haters, they won't last long. Like if somebody joined our Twitch chat right now and started hating, they wouldn't last long.
Nobody's going to react to their stuff. They're not going to get the, you know, the banter of, yeah, Evan sucks or whatever it is, right?
So they'll leave and they'll go somewhere else where that hate is more welcome.
So there was just more comment for those of you who are out creating and are worried about haters.
If you're involved, if you're involved in the community, you'll build a positive one if you're positive.
And now in terms of advice, I think there's two parts to it. One was the legal side.
You said you couldn't get a license. And second was actually what to do.
Okay. I'm banning the champion. I'm going to make sure I don't ban my Teemo this time.
Good. For the license, you know, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not a lawyer and I'm not American either.
So I would just check your local area to see. But that stuff, you can't let that hold you back.
Right. Like, so, so start a business with your parents name or your older brother or, you know, your uncle or, you know, just find somebody to help you do it.
Right. That's, that's going to be the least of your concerns. Right.
You're going to have tons of roadblocks and entrepreneurship is about overcoming those roadblocks.
That's what you need to do. So just find, find somebody to help you. That's really a restriction.
I'm not convinced that it is. But if it really is a restriction, then just find somebody to help you.
The thing with fashion is it's so easy to lose money. It's so easy to spend all your money on, on product and then, and then buy the wrong product and never, never sell out.
Right. And then you have 10,000 t-shirts sitting in your mom's basement.
So to start, you have to prove that your designs work and you have to know which designs are going to work.
And so what I would recommend is using a print on demand service.
Find the one that you like. There's tons of them online and even a lot of local shops will now print on demand too.
So that you're not spending, you're spending zero money at the start. You're only spending money when you're making money.
Or you do a Kickstarter campaign or any of the other crowdfunding sources to show your design, raise the money for the t-shirts or whatever it is you're making.
And if you don't raise enough money, you're not actually producing it. So you're not out. I don't want you spending money. Stop spending money.
Go out and, and build, you know, like create an amazing design where I look at it and say, that's sick.
Oh, hold on. Let me pick my champion here, team. Oh, that design is sick.
I need to have it. And I should be able to look at it and want to order it.
Right. And if it, you know, if I'm not your target audience, fine, but your target audience, you want to look at the design you came up with and want to order it.
Right. And so it was a Kickstarter campaign. If it's print on demand, you know, you test, you test your ideas, you test your designs, you test to see which one is going to work best.
And then, you know, people don't do it because you don't make a lot of money doing that. Right.
If you're selling a T-shirt on a print on demand service, you may make a dollar, two dollars, five dollars a T-shirt instead of 20, 25 dollars a T-shirt.
But you're not looking at the fixed cost. Right. You're not looking at that big order that you need to place to be able to get those T-shirts coming in.
So it's much better to do print on demand or Kickstarter crowdfunding source to make sure that your design hits.
Because most of them won't hit. Right. You're going to experiment just like a singer's first song is really going to hit, a YouTuber's first video is really going to hit.
You're going to have to experiment, experiment, experiment until you find a design that works.
And once you find one that's really taking off, you could pull it. Like, you could pull it from your print on demand service and say, you know what, we're getting enough interest in this.
I'm going to go out and buy 5,000 shirts and start to sell this. But you're able to do it because you have money coming in.
And so that's what I would focus on and hopefully that helps. I don't want to see your designs too. Maybe I'll wear one.
Nice.
That's what I got.
Yeah. And Rise Online provided a link to Printful.com. I think that's in regards to printing on demand.
All right. I see a bunch of coffee chatter happening in the Twitch live stream. They're not paying attention to us. They're just talking coffee.
Basically.
It's all good. All right. What's next? Who do we got?
All right. Cool. So next question is coming from BF Williams Jr. And BF is asking, he says there's one thing that has bothered me as of late.
I have crazy pain. What is going on?
Pain?
Pain. Pain. Pain. It means that I'm going to, if I don't, something's happened with my internet. Maybe we're uploading a video or something.
Oh, that looks better. Okay. I don't know if you see this number. Maybe, oh, you're going to be delayed.
Usually the pain, I don't know what it stands for. I don't know. The techies here will know what it stands for.
Usually I play around, you know, 30, 30, it's usually 30 ping where if you go higher, it means you're, everything else is delayed.
So you delay, you're delayed in how you see the game going on and your own moves as well.
And I was at like a 200 ping, which means I would click and then like two seconds later, my guy would move.
So it's, uh, dangerous, very dangerous if you're playing one of these kind of games and you have high pain, but we're good.
Okay. So yes, back into the question.
Okay. Um, so we, uh, yeah, so he's basically saying there's something that's really bothered him and he is coming to you because he knows you have experience, um, in this area.
But he's dealing with a really difficult breakup. Okay. And he says, I know that you mentioned your divorce early on in your channel and I appreciate the vulnerability.
Is there anything you can share with your viewers to get over a bad breakup when you really cared about the person?
Uh, I mean, something beyond the classic cliches we hear so much about, there are more fish in the sea, it's their loss, et cetera.
I know there are several similarities in matters of the heart when it comes to breaking up and also entrepreneurship.
So I figured I'd ask you, I don't even have the heart to try another relationship right now.
I'm stuck looking into my rear view mirror. My ex is engaged to be married 10 months after we split.
She didn't waste any time. Doesn't seem like she grieved, um, like I am. On to the next.
Looks like she's the one that should be the entrepreneur.
Mm. Okay. Hope you caught all that, Evan.
Yep, yep, I heard.
All right. Um, yeah, well, you're right. Evan has a lot of wisdom and area of relationship.
And there are, there are a lot of like parallels between, you know, the entrepreneurship journey and just relationships.
And, and I think a lot of the principles are the same because, you know, it's life and life can get really rough.
You know, learn how to move forward. Um, I definitely have, I have one particular breakup that I know was just pretty horrible.
Um, and I was thinking about, okay, what were the things that I learned from that time that, you know, I think I would have really appreciated.
And I think one of the things I will say is understand that, you know, it is, it is difficult.
But I think one of the things that actually makes it easier that I didn't do was really own my feelings about it.
Um, and I think you just writing Evan and sharing all this, you are steps ahead of where I think I was at because I think I was so scared of experiencing the loss and the pain and the emotion of it that I was like, I went into serious like, uh, overcomer mode, which is like, you know, keep going, keep pressing, you know,
and there's something that is good about that. But I think there probably was more of accepting and owning how pain, how much pain actually was, and just like letting that be okay to not be okay.
And, um, I also think that it just makes the grieving process go much longer when you don't really authentically grieve.
So if it hurts, okay, like own that it hurts and just sit in the hat, you know, and accept it. And then I think you can actually move past it quicker when you actually just own it.
Um, the other thing I'll say is that I think it's really helpful that you, if you can't get a counselor, just have someone in your life that will be able to support you through it.
Because for two reasons, you get that support of having someone there when you're needing the extra support, but you also learn about yourself. Like you learn, I think you can get quicker to figuring out what didn't work.
And, um, I think it's important to learn from the, from the quote unquote failed relationship so that you can understand, you know, maybe what you want next time.
And then finally, this is just this, this might be cliche wisdom, but I really love this. And I it's really carried me a lot. And it's that TD Jakes, one of my favorite entrepreneurs
and motivational speakers, preachers, teachers, and he says, man's rejection is God's protection. And just recognizing as much as that might be kind of cliche, it's recognizing that the doors that close for you are for you.
They're not, you know, it's happening for you, not to you, and that it's getting you closer to the next thing. So I don't know, I think that might be cliche, but it helps me a lot.
A lot of love. Um, this is an interesting one. I don't know that I've been asked this, so, uh, I have to think about it a little bit more and the circumstances here are great for me having to think about things a little more.
Um, also super humbled that, uh, you know, you would ask me that and hopefully I can give you some, some guidance and help. Um, the things that come to mind for me are one, uh, dealing with the immediate impact and then two, kind of figuring yourself out for the longer run.
Uh, I've been through two, two, uh, you know, painful breakups, I guess, in, in my life. Um, both of, you know, multi-year, you know, relationship level. Um, the short term thing that's always helped me, uh, is I, I have to get lost in, I just get lost in the work.
Like I get lost in doing whatever, whatever, you know, it is that I need to do. Um, I remember my first one, I was dating a girl in university for five years and then we broke up, um, in, I don't know, it was like three in the morning or something.
And, uh, I just got in the car and, and drove around the highway and, you know, totally empty. And that was like, that was the worst, that was the worst of it. Um, and then I just started, you know, at that time I had a different business.
At that time it was just, just go back into the business, be around people who support me and, and do work because the pain was too much to handle that if, if I, I don't, I don't know that this is the right thing to do by the way, it's just what I did and it, it helped.
Um, so, you know, see, see if it works for you or not. But, um, whenever I was by myself, even sleeping would be, would be rough. Uh, and so I didn't sleep much and I just used whatever time I had to work.
And thankfully I was doing work that I liked, right? Um, I've always had that where I'm doing, well, since I started my entrepreneurial stuff, always had that where I'm doing work that I like. Um, oh, there's a big fight happening, team's about to die. Let's see what happens.
Um, so I think that was, that was super helpful in the short term, like in the, in the week, the week immediately after where it was most painful, just getting lost in my work and being around people and not being by myself and not feeling, you know, sorry for myself.
Um, and just trying not, trying not to think about it, uh, helped me at least, uh, you know, he may already be past that stage now in, in, um, you know, where he's at with his recovery. Uh, but I found that super helpful for me.
Uh, the next part is more of a mental game as well as a self-confidence game where, you know, when you're dealing with rejection, whether it's a, you know, a relationship or a client doesn't need you, doesn't want to work with you anymore or, you know, whatever it is.
Um, it's understanding that it is probably for everybody's best, right? Like if somebody really doesn't want to be with you, then why would you want to be with them too? Uh, there's, there's somebody better out there for you.
Not that there's, not that there's plenty of fish in the sea and there's, you know, like tons of people, but there's, there's one person out there that's, that's better for you and more aligned with you, um, than what you had.
And same thing with clients. You know, there's, if the client doesn't want to work with you, there is better clients out there for you. You don't have to go be somebody that you're not to try to appease one client.
And no matter how much you try, it just doesn't seem to be working out. The best thing to do is probably leave that client and go do something else. And it sucks when you're the one kind of giving more to the relationship and you really want it to work out and it's not.
Um, so I, it's, it's, uh, it's easy to say, but hard to do. It's hard to actually feel it. Uh, but you know, with time, at least I've found that the more you tell yourself that and the more you start to believe it because it is actually true and is important part of, uh, of healing.
Um, the second and maybe deeper issue is not putting so much of your self worth, uh, in somebody else's hands. And that takes a ton of practice and it's not something that, you know, we're really taught in schools.
But we're doing a video and then espresso coming up soon with, uh, Tyrese Gibson, the guy from the Fast and the Furious. And he has a great little speech that he goes off on.
On, uh, not like I know I'm great. You know, whether you stop thinking I'm great, I still know that I'm great. Um, maybe TD Jakes? No, it's not TD Jakes. It's Quincy Jones who said something similar where it's, uh, you know, not one ounce of my self worth is tied up in how you think of me.
Uh, and I think, especially when it comes to rejection and relationships, we care. If you want to have a successful relationship, at least what I found is you need to love yourself first.
You need to be happy with who you are first and not need that other person to give you the validation that you are good, that you are acceptable. Uh, and you shouldn't be able to, if you can bring that to a relationship, it makes it much stronger.
Uh, I feel like I'm happy with my life and I want you in it, not, I need you here to be happy because it also puts an unfair amount of pressure on your partner.
Uh, where if you can both enter a relationship with that mindset mentality, um, you're much more likely to, uh, to have success, at least in my humble opinion.
Um, yeah. And, and it sucks, you know, I, I, I feel the, I feel the pain, you know, and, and for me, the second one with, with my divorce, I had, uh, Hayden too, right?
So when there's kids involved, it's, it's, uh, you always want to try to work harder to make sure that it works out, but I'm also so much happier with Nina.
Um, but before I could be, before I could be ready for Nina, I had to, I had to love myself more and I was actually holding myself down too much in my past relationship to try to make the relationship work.
I held myself down from what I could be, uh, and it's not a knock against, against, um, you know, my ex wife.
So she, she probably felt the same way to be honest. And it's just a case of two people not being the right fit.
Um, so those are my thoughts. Good luck.
Nice. Yeah. I think just what's so hard about breakups in general is that like some things are just time too. You know, you can't, you can't like do anything about the fact that some, some pain just doesn't go away.
You can't do anything and just take away the pain right now. That's just one of the things that's so hard about it.
But great advice. We got a question from the chat.
All right.
For ya. Yeah. And let us know how the game's going.
Okay. That's what they wanted to know. How's the game going?
No, I was asking if I was getting the question.
Oh, the game we're three and five. I'm, uh, I'm, I'm, I'm getting some rage from my teammates for not helping out more.
I'm that last question. I was, uh, trying to think, trying to think and help. And so, uh, I was not, uh, as in tune in, uh, the game as I should be.
So getting, getting some hate from my teammates here, but it's all good.
Okay.
All right. We've got a question from C.
Rather rather, um, and I actually don't know if the brother is a girl or a guy. Sorry.
If I'm thinking it's a guy, he says, Evan, should I focus on websites only or should I make a website?
Android and iOS app. So let me read that again. Evan, should I focus on websites only or should I make a website?
This is, this is within our chat. Okay. I don't really get it. Should I focus on websites only or should I make a website?
And then he says, Android and iOS app.
Oh, okay. So should you make websites or should you make apps?
I think that's the question.
Brother, if we're wrong about that, let us know.
Okay.
What, what do you, you, I think you better answer this one.
No, Rishi, this is, Rishi kept perspective.
You need the Rishi perspective.
I think, I think I didn't, the main thing is, is that I want to know, I think I'm not fully sure still on the question, but, um, what do you want to do?
See, rather tell us a little bit more about your business and, and what do you want to do?
Oh, okay. Here he says, he says, should I make a website for all devices or should I make a website, Android and iOS app?
Oh, so an app or a mobile site.
Sounds like if you do an app, like does it, does it make sense for your business to, to have a, to make an app or just do a website that, uh, that people can access from the different platforms?
Uh, that's okay. Okay.
I guess my take on it, I think it really just depends on, um, what you, what the behavior of the customers are.
I think you definitely need a website. I would start with the web. If you're promoting a business, you know, whatever, I don't know what the business is, but assuming he has a business, if you're promoting a business, you need to have a website so people can find you.
Um, and from there, are people going to then install an app? Does it, does it make sense for the behavior of the customers to use an app or not? Maybe it does. Maybe it doesn't.
Um, you know, Toronto Dance Salsa, we have a website. We don't have an app. You know, could we use an app? Maybe. Would people use the app? Maybe.
Um, oh, I'm going to see if I can help Jay. Oh, Jay got a kill, but he died. All right. I was too late.
Uh, so he says, he says, because can't all smartphones go to websites now?
Yes. Smartphones go to websites. You just need to make sure that the, the app is, uh, sorry, the, the, the mobile site is designed for mobile, right? That when I look at the website on my phone, it's, it's designed for it.
Um, so I have a good experience. So if I was just getting started and I had a regular business, I would definitely go mobile site first and then see, you know, how many people are coming from mobile?
Uh, are there different, you know, scenarios where somebody would want to have an app where it'd be actually useful for them versus just having a mobile website?
Um, and if you don't know, then I would definitely start with the mobile site and then see what the feedback is and then move the app if needed.
Great. He says, thank you. Great answer. Love to lead teams.
No problem. Thanks for the question. I like the live, I like the live responses there. It's good.
Yeah. Rise Online says it's all about providing value.
How is Rise Online playing and answering questions?
I don't know. How are you?
Well, yeah, I guess I have a split screen, but I think he's playing off a laptop, but I'm, I'm feeling it.
Cool. Um, well, we've got, uh, another question in the chat.
Okay.
Uh, Soul Forged 2453. What is the goal of a business and or website for what? Oh, are you, I think he's actually, uh, no, he's not giving a question. He's giving value.
He says, what is the goal of the business or website? What market is it?
Yep.
I think he's just given value. Nice Soul Forged. Way to, way to give the love.
I love it.
All right. Um, next question is coming from Alexander and Alexander says, Hey Evan, I just wanted to take a moment to thank you for what you've accomplished in your life. I'm really proud of you as a Canadian.
Canada love. Thank you, Alexander.
He's from Quebec.
All right.
And he says, you make a great job for my life. And I would like to know what kind of software you use to take short parts of other videos to make your top 10.
So do you use a particular software to create your, all the different, uh, footage for the top 10 videos?
Uh, so for me, I started off doing, like right now, the short answer is I have an editor.
Uh, I actually, since the top 10, I've had an editor. I haven't done a single one of the top 10 myself.
Um, so yeah, that's, that's the short answer. Um, I started off on this YouTube journey, you know, as I've said, lots of times on my channel, I hate spending money until I'm making money.
So I started off doing everything myself and, uh, you know, I, I sucked my way through it. I use Windows Movie Maker to start.
Um, and that was a good start. It's easy to use. So if you're a, if you're, you know, total noob at editing, uh, it was super helpful for me.
I moved to Camtasia, which was a little bit, uh, well, a lot, a bit more complicated, but also gave more functionality.
Um, so that took me a while to learn. And as I was just starting to figure that out, my YouTube channel was starting to make me some money.
And the first thing I did was hire an editor because it was what I was least interested in.
I was least good at it, but most importantly, I was least interested in it because if I, if I was interested, but, but sucked at it, I could get better.
If you're interested in learning something, you'll get better. You just will. Um, I'm in the fight there. Okay.
But I wasn't, I didn't want to get better at it. You know, it wasn't, wasn't on my bucket list to be a better, uh, video editor.
So I stopped and I hired that out. Um, and once I started doing the top tens, I was already, I was already, uh, I already had an editor.
So, so yeah, I don't know that I can help that much there, but, uh, you could do it. You could do it within Movie Maker. You could do it within Camtasia.
You know, it's, what do you use Rishi?
Um, I use iMovie.
Right.
Um, yeah. And I think, um, do you have to have a special license when you are utilizing footage from other videos?
Is there a special license you have to have for that or how does that work?
Um, there can be, it depends, depends on the source. Some people, um, some people really care and some people don't.
So some people, you know, it's just special arrangements that I've made with them. Um, so I don't know what he wants to do.
If he's just going to go like randomly out on YouTube and take videos or what the plan is, but, um, yeah.
Just make sure you're not infringing, Alexander, because I also know that YouTube will definitely, well, I don't know how much they really check that stuff, but I know they say.
Well, it also depends what your goal is too. Like if you're, if you're using third party music, for example, expect to never get monetized.
Like you'll never make, you'll never be able to monetize the video and make money from YouTube.
Um, monetization has never been my main goal though. Right? Like I started doing this for myself to learn, to have, um, deeper knowledge about entrepreneurship and, you know, have, uh, have a better environment for myself.
And I share that and I know a lot of the videos we don't make anything from, uh, but it's fine. Like the short term monetization is not the goal of the channel. So.
Right. Nice. Yeah.
You know, uh, say I started with windows movie maker, moved on to Sony Vegas pro and now it's all Adobe for me.
Um, cool. You know, thanks for Zano. Thanks for the, for the value there.
Cool.
So, uh, next question comes from Joseph and Joseph actually doesn't have a question. Joseph says, Hey Evan, how are you doing my friend?
I'm awesome, Joseph. I'm feeling the love. How are you guys doing? I love the question.
Occasionally we get a comment, something like that to say, Hey, how you doing? I like that. I like it. I like it. Thank you, Joseph. I'm rocking. How are you doing Rishi?
I'm doing great.
And then, and also just one question that we do get from people is like, how do I get my question? So if you're not already in the live chat,
um, you can get your questions in by, uh, emailing Evan. So that's where these question comes from. Um, so get on Evan's mailing list and join the party.
Yeah. Most of them are just responses. So if people who write new, um, read my newsletter and then respond, I respond with the question with the video.
Yeah. Awesome. Uh, okay. Thanks.
Demosta says I use HitFilm express. Never heard of that one. Interesting. Okay.
So next question is coming from Kishore and Kishore says, where are your favorite apps hiding?
Where are my favorite apps hiding?
Yeah. He wants to know what your favorite apps are.
Okay. I got it.
Um, my favorite right now, I know, uh, everybody kind of likes this, but I really like Evernote. It's kind of saving me right now in a couple of things for my life.
Um, and then I actually just, I'm kind of excited about this. I just recently, uh, started using an app called cups.
And what cups? What?
That's appropriate.
I would say so. And basically it just is an app that helps you, uh, they want to support local small business coffee shops.
And so basically, you know, it's just a way to support local coffee shops, but also you can like use it to, to do everything you would do without even having to like go through the cashier.
And it's cool. It's just a convenient app for that. But honestly, I haven't really started using it. I just liked the fact that they were going to give me my first $5 for free or my first cup of coffee for free.
So I got $5 for my first cup of coffee. I'm really excited about.
Yeah. So I'll let you guys know how it goes. Cause I really haven't started using it, but that's my most recent app. What about you Evan?
Uh, I don't know that I'm a great person to ask cause I'm not really into app culture. Uh, I think a lot of it is just a waste of time. Um, I don't, I don't use a cell phone, you know, I don't, I don't have a data package.
Um, the only thing that might, like if I was traveling more than I probably would just for Uber, cause I can't really use Uber cause I don't have a data package, but if I was traveling more, I probably would. I would look at it. Um, apps that I use.
Yeah. Everything you have to take with a grain of salt, you know, and that I'm only using apps when I'm connected to wifi. Um, or they can be used offline. I'm a big Evernote fan though. All my notes are never known, uh, for all my, you know, projects and meetings and ideas.
It's, it's my external brain hard drive. Um, and I like that it's on all my devices so I can, if I add a note on my computer, it'll go to my, it'll go to my desktop, uh, and it'll go to my phone and it'll go to iPad or whatever device. Um, what else do I use?
I mean, I use Fitbit for tracking steps. Um, email as boring as that is, you know, I use, most of the time I'm just using email. I respond to people using offline, the offline mode on email. Um, what else do I use? I'm trying to think.
It's a lot of boring stuff guys. Oh, I'm going to die. I didn't die. Oh, I might still die. I died. Very sad. Um, let me, well, now that I died, let me load my phone. Let's see what's on here. I have a phone, but it's not, there's no, again, there's no data on here. Right.
Uh, oh, I love using Feedly. Feedly is for news. Look, my main apps that I have in the bottom are Feedly, email, Chrome, and my camera. And then under tools, I have Evernote. It's basically it. I don't, I don't tweet. I don't use the calendar much. We kind of use Headspace.
Does Nina have a phone and does she like to do apps on app stuff? She likes Pokemon Go, doesn't she?
Nina, Nina, Nina likes Pokemon Go. On the iPad, she has an app that, uh, lets her watch Chinese TV shows.
Oh, cool.
She plays Gordon Ramsey's, uh, Cook Off or whatever it's called.
Yay.
Yeah. So Nina, Nina uses the phone a lot for, uh, messaging. She's got all sorts of different apps. There's, you know, there's the, there's the regular apps that we're all familiar with, you know, but then there's also the Chinese apps that she's, you know, really in love.
Oh, I died. She's a hate thing. Um, Chinese messaging apps, uh, you know, all the other messaging apps. She, she's big on keeping in touch with people. She loves doing that.
Um, it's really core to her. She keeps in touch with people from grade one that she, you know, went to school with. Um, I'm not the, I'm not, I don't do that. I don't really enjoy that.
Um, uh, just as an example, like Alex recently moved, he moved yesterday and I'm like, do you need help moving? I'll come over. Do you need help? Do you need food? Do you need any support? And he's like, no, we're good. You can come by and say hi if you want, but, um, we don't need help moving.
And I have zero interest, right? I have zero interest in coming by anybody's place just to say hi.
He understands though. He's not, he's not, uh, he's not offended by it. Um, but it's true. Like the time I'm spending, it has to be impactful. I want to have an impact on people's lives.
And, uh, and it's not going to come from, uh, just saying hi. So that's, uh, that's my own, it's my own thing, I guess. But, uh, anyway, yeah, we're getting some kills. We're getting some kills. Hopefully, hopefully, hopefully die. Yeah.
Nice. That's like, that's like my favorite thing in the world is like to come over just to say hi. Yeah. But I will do way more than most people on everything else. Right? Like I will show up. I will buy you pizza. I will, I will work. Like if you're struggling, I will, I will cancel all my plans to come and help you.
Yes. I know this is true. Uh, you know, I will, I will put my business at risk, you know, put off things that I need to do to help the important people in my life, but I won't come by and say hi.
It's why I hate most weddings, you know, most corporate functions, all that stuff. Cause my presence doesn't really matter. You know, like, you know, when Alex is going to get married, I'll, I'm going to go to that.
When most people get married though, when you're like one of, of, you know, 300 people and nobody really notices if you're there or not, that drives me nuts.
Um, it's because I value my time. I have important things that I want to get done in this world. And, uh, so I get frustrated when I'm not using my time well.
Um, and I get that that might be offensive to some people, but I, I try not to, I have to explain it.
I'm not, yeah, I'm not offended by it. It's just, it's fascinating to me because I think of also there's this, uh, particular, uh, kind of like a personality test if you just want to generalize it.
And, uh, one of the seven life languages, which if you guys have seen that video on my channel, like there's the, the mover and the mover is like, um, an example of a mover would be Mel Gibson and Braveheart.
And like, he's just like, I need to like lead the nation. And that's all movers want to do. They just want to make an impact, get it.
They're go, go, go, do, do, do. And so I'm, I'm always wondering what your highest life language is because I'm, I'm assuming it's a mover, but it makes sense.
So it's not offensive when you know that, you know, different people have just different, they're, we're all different for different reasons. So it's kind of cool.
All right.
Okay.
What was the original question they were answering there? I don't even remember anymore.
That, that was your favorite app.
Ah, right.
Yep.
So next question is coming from Katongi. Katongi. And he says, how does one make money on YouTube?
So yeah, that's a question that we, we also get a lot. There's several ways, um, that you can make money on YouTube. And I think we've talked a lot about how the monetization by being a YouTube partner, you know, that's an option for you, but don't expect to make money anytime soon.
Um, and I think some of the other answers that I've typically given have been about, you know, you could do, um, now I can't think about it, affiliate marketing. Um, you know, there's just so many ways. But one, one thing that I don't think I've ever mentioned that I think is, um, important is, you know, you could think about selling courses online.
Um, we've talked on this channel a lot about service based businesses being a great way to generate cash flow, um, sooner than later. And so I'd be thinking too, um, if you, if you like the idea of, um, teaching or giving information, that's another way to that people have used YouTube to, um, to get money.
But there's a, there's a lot of different ways and I think there is diverse as there are YouTube creators.
I'm in a fight and I got a kill. Super excited about that. I'm in another fight and another kill. Holy cow. Well, Timo's doing work. My team, my team is feeding, but Timo is doing work.
Uh, how to make money on YouTube. One of our favorite questions, huh? Yeah. How to make money on YouTube. Well, what, what more, uh, what added context can we give beyond our typical, our typical answer?
I know. Um, I think first off is understanding that, uh, you have to want to do videos. Like if you're just looking at YouTube because you think you can make a lot of money or you're going after fame, like stop it. You're going to lose.
Uh, you have to do, you have to do it cause you love making videos. Somehow you want to have to, you have a message, you want to spread it. Um, it's super important. Uh, you would do it even if you weren't making money where that is definitely not the mentality and approach of most people who are trying to make YouTube videos.
Whoa. I'm fighting. I am fighting. I am. Am I doing well? Am I doing well? Am I going to get this guy? I think I'm going to get this guy. Nice. Um, yeah. Timo is doing work. I am 13 and three. So, uh, I'm doing some serious work on this team.
Um, okay, let's get to the question. So yes, you gotta be able to, you're going to have to want to do videos. You have to, you know, feel it in your bones. You got to want to make the videos even if you're not making money.
Um, you know, and that's where most people don't do it, right? That's where most people are. They fall down, right? Most people are in it for the wrong reasons. And so, uh, so they don't get to the success for, for the 1% chance that he's actually trying to make videos for the right reason.
And really, you know, um, has a passion for it. Then the, the best way to make money is, is actually not going to be through the advertising platform. Uh, you have to see yourself as a brand and all the things that that brand could potentially build.
Um, and so, you know, most of the money that I will make is not just coming from YouTube advertising, but coming from the deals that I'll close. And I'm, I'm, I'm leaving a lot of money, short term money on the table as well.
You know, I'm not, you know, I have my book coming out and I'm talking about that, but I'm not pimping out other products, um, that I could be pimping out. I could be promoting and marketing and trying to, you know, short term cash infusion if I needed it.
Um, but I'm focused on building, building a brand that will last. I'm focused on trying to get people, um, to see me as somebody who's really interested in investing and helping them build something important.
Uh, and hopefully with that, you know, comes a lot of future opportunities working with, um, working with brands, getting other product deals.
Um, let me kill him. Oh, we both killed each other. Very sad. Um, so that's, that's where I get a lot of my, uh, the bigger money, right? Making brand deals, book deals, if you get into clothing lines, your own products, you look at the big YouTubers where they're making their money.
Um, it's, it's some from, um, the monetization of the videos, but most of it's coming off of YouTube somehow.
Uh, Tim, who, who everybody's a big fan of, Tim Schmoyer, um, he does a regular kind of update of how he's doing and the, the biggest, uh, income source for him is his courses.
So he has these courses that he sells and, um, that's where he makes the biggest majority of his money. It's 50% or something of his revenue.
So people kept asking him, how do I have success on YouTube? Um, and he has his videos, which makes some monetization, but I think YouTube monetization for him is, is somewhere in the teens, like percentage wise, something teen percent.
Um, so it's not a big chunk and then it comes from providing services, uh, doing coaching, right? I don't do coaching, but I could, but it's where it's from, providing coaching services.
Um, I bought the wrong item. Very sad. Very sad. Uh, but really chances are you need to work on, uh, actually caring about video, doing this because you love doing this, doing this, you do it regardless.
Um, and if you don't have that, then you're not going to be, you're not going to have the success you're after.
We got good meets nice in the chat saying, Hey Evan, uh, go for Drake Baron next time. Two to three enemies are dead. Oh, the next time two to three enemies are dead.
Thank you for that love. I appreciate it.
Yeah, I think, I think courses would be something I'd really enjoy, uh, eventually just because it, I think it, I love teaching and I like, um, the idea of being able to, um, that seems to be something that I think I'd really enjoy. So, um, yeah, I think I, you know, I think about that sometimes when I think about, you know, as I continue to
solidify, you know, the, the service and the value that I want to provide, I think I really enjoy courses. So yeah, I mean, I could make, I could make a ton if I wanted to from my channel, just doing consulting, all these people were asking questions. I can say, Hey, buy my coaching package and for X amount a month, you know, you can come on.
There's tons of ways to monetize it, but it has to be, it has to be right for you. Uh, and as you grow, as you gain an audience, there'll be lots of opportunities to open up. A lot that I didn't even think of. I didn't think I'd make any brand deals. I didn't think a brand would want to hire me because I tell people to go start a business.
So what, what brand is going to want to hire me to, to come and talk? Cause I'm going to tell their employees go start a business. Right. Um, Oh, let me save Jay. Oh, he's out. Okay. Um, so I didn't think, I didn't think brands would hire me, but then we found, you know, Stephen Kelly and Sage and all they wanted to do, um, to end up being a good fit actually.
Whoa. The fight is real. The fights are real. Nice. Nice. Okay. We're doing work. Team is doing work.
Oh, so I made a mistake earlier. Good meat's nice. That message was, uh, for Ethan. Is there an Ethan in the game that I'm unaware of?
Ethan? No, maybe just, maybe just misspelled.
I thought so too, but he's saying, he's correcting me and saying Ethan.
I'm not, I'm not feeling it. Wait, but good mean that good meat.
Science was the guy saying that I should buy, I should go after Baron. Right. He was giving the game advice. Yeah. So maybe he's just messing with me.
I think, I think he just, I don't know. Um, so, you know, I mean, I got, I got offered an opportunity to join the board of a publicly traded company, uh, to be a mentor and advisor for them.
You know, that's something I would never have thought of in my business model. Um, but as you grow, as you gain an audience, a lot of opportunities come to you that, uh, that you may not have recognized or even thought of before.
But it all stems from making awesome content that people want to watch, want to engage with, want to learn from. And so that's where you need to start.
Yeah, that's cool. I, you gotta let us know how that goes. I think that's cool.
Alrighty. Yep. Let's do it. Next question comes from Rocio and Rocio is asking, um, I'm looking to venture out as an entrepreneur.
I love acting in public speaking and train daily for this, but like anything, we need to make money. I thought of different ideas such as social media marketing and coaching, but I'm having a hard time starting this. I really need guidance and I would really appreciate your help.
Alright. Another concerned money question. Um, now feeling the, feeling the struggle because so many of the entrepreneurs, you know, they want to be able to get started, but they are feeling held back by the money and the lack thereof.
So, um, you love acting in public speaking. Definitely lots of, you know, if you're going to go out there and just look for a job, there's definitely lots of jobs that could utilize your love for acting and your love for public speaking.
Um, so I think it takes a little bit of time on your part just to kind of get out there and search, but I also, uh, found an article in entrepreneur that was called the five jobs. Every entrepreneur should work before building a business.
And, um, you know, I love the advice, get a job in the field or in the industry that you want to build a business in because it gives you the knowledge and the experience and you'll love what you do.
But I thought it was an interesting article that you may want to also check out because it lists five jobs that is basically give you some of the practical skills, um, for entrepreneurship, which there's definitely value there.
One of which was, hey, work at McDonald's. Why? Because you learn how to work in a high pressured environment where you're learning how to multitask, you're learning how to just basically sink or swim in an environment that's high pressure.
But anyway, in the article called five jobs, every entrepreneur should work. Another perspective that we might not talk so much about on so far.
So the question again was he wants to act, but, uh, isn't making money from acting. And so now wants to find ways to make money and is looking at social media as a way to do it. Like social media consulting or something.
Yeah. His passion is to be an entrepreneur. He says he loves acting and public speaking, but yeah, he, he's feeling like I need money at this point and he's trying to figure out ways of making money, social media marketing or coaching or things that he thought of, but he's just having a hard time starting and doesn't would like your guidance.
Got it. Um, it's an interesting one.
I think when I look at, you know, there's a lot of people who, who, uh, who want to be actors and end up going to Hollywood and you know, uh, working in waitress jobs or whatever it is to try to, you know, pay the bills.
Whoa, we're in a big fight. Can I pull it off? Can I pull it off? I'm going to get them. I got one. No, I didn't. It's a, this is really stressful time here at the end of the game, but, uh, we might lose this. Our team is, our team is, team is struggling.
Um, I would say the best thing you can do if you're struggling, you're not making money, uh, is one, get a job in the industry to learn, uh, to learn how to provide value, to make some connections, to learn how, you know, the game works.
And at the same time, do something on the side to start building your business, whatever that is.
Um, oh, am I going to get him? I'm going to get him. I'm going to get him. I'm going to get him. Die. Ha ha ha. Um, so whatever business you're trying to build up, did he say what kind of company you wanted to start or just that he wants to be an entrepreneur?
Just wants to be an entrepreneur.
Yeah. So, so start being an entrepreneur and at the same time work for someone to like, I wouldn't go get necessarily McDonald's job, but I would try to get a job where I'm going to learn something, build some connections, you know, where I can use that knowledge to plow into my, uh, eventual, you know, success as a, as a entrepreneur.
Um, so those two things really, that's it. Um, get a job to learn and start making money, start paying the bills. I'm not as coherent as I usually am because I'm in a, this is a kind of insane fight happening right now.
Uh, and, and then start learning, uh, start, start your business on the side, right? Like the worst thing I think you do is get a job where you're not learning anything and it's just to pay the bills.
You know, you have to, you have to learn from the jobs, even if your end goal is something else, you can learn from those jobs. Um, so who's done something that is, that is up your alley, that is really interesting, that you really respect and admire,
that you want to be like in a couple of years, you know, ideally a smaller company where you can, uh, um, you can take on multiple jobs and learn a lot and not just be stuck, you know, serving coffee to people and doing really boring stuff in a bigger business.
Um, until you get to the point where your business is ready to rock and roll on its own.
So back to your landscaping job, what did your landscaping job, what skill did that give you for what you're doing now?
Um, hustle?
Yeah, I guess. I mean, honestly, I think that's much more case of like me just being able to pull something from every experience. I think you can pull something from every experience that you, you know, go through in life.
And that was what that really was for me much more than with intent and purpose. I tried to go out and do this. I think if that were me today and I was in that situation, I would have tried to pick a job that was more like I was lazy.
Uh, in my job search, you know, I wanted to get a job where I could learn. I felt like I couldn't because I only had two months out of the summer where people who wanted to hire, you know, real summer interns, I guess, in my field wanted people who could do the whole summer.
Um, and so I felt like the only opportunity available to me was doing, um, doing, uh, landscaping, but really I had an in, you know, like it was a friend of the family. I had an in, it was kind of easier for me to do. So I, I was lazy.
Now, what did I take from it? I still took that. I was, I still, you know, put in a lot of hustle and bet on myself and, you know, did a lot of things that, uh, you know, others might not, you know, um, am I going to kill her? Yes, I am. Very exciting, but I died.
Um, if I were doing it again, I would pick a different job, but, uh, but I still, I still think you can learn from everything. And I learned my, my hustle and heart and drive and try to, uh, make the best of it and not, not give in and push myself and understand what my limits are.
But, you know, I probably could have picked something better if I had more intent, you know, things you learn along the path, you know, 19 year old Evan didn't know as much.
Oh, it looks like the game done.
Nope. It's close. So the next big fight, somebody is going to win. It's close.
Okay. Yeah. I just say, I don't know if you know the seven, but there's, even with great wifi, there's always about a 15 minute delay from me on my end. So sometimes I'm like, oh, maybe I don't know what's going on after all.
All right. Next question is coming from Fatima. Fatima says, I hope you are fine by the grace of God. I am 22 years old. I am doing bachelor's in textile and fashion design and also doing a job with a Pakistani diplomat.
My salary is 25,000 rupees only. I want to do so many things in my life, but my salary is so much less, too much less. I want to open an old house or orphan house, but I have no idea how I can fulfill one. I don't know I can fulfill this wish. I need your guidance.
So, all right. And how much is 25,000 rupees? I don't know the conversion. Does anybody know? Because that's not a money conversion that I know. But anyway, I know clearly she's saying very little and she's wanting to do fashion.
And I guess the answer is kind of similar and could be applied to our earlier young entrepreneur who is a aspiring designer and no money. Again, I'll just say check out for sure the videos on Evan's channel about this very subject. There are at least two that you could go ahead and watch.
But I think, too, another thing that is especially with fashion or with clothing, there's so many opportunities for a global market where you can start something online.
And I know that I think we had a previous caller or a previous question about this on another episode, but you can go ahead and start putting your stuff up now on a pre-existing site and just start testing the market for do you get people who are customers and that like your fashion designs.
And if you're getting enough traction, then you can start reinvesting that money into your business and maybe eventually have your own online site.
But I think the great thing nowadays is that even if you are in any country, you can do things globally. And so I suggest starting to try to sell your stuff online now on a site that already exists before you jump in and do your own.
Can you? So I'm just trying to wrap my head around. He's got a ton of ideas of what he wants to do in his entrepreneurial career, feels hands-strong from not having enough money.
Okay. And then I'm going to die. I'm going to die. I'm going to die. I'm going to die. Yep. I had four people on me. Very sad.
And then the main business that he wanted to start was in fashion. Was that how you got onto the fashion?
Yeah. So the main aspiration is basically to do fashion design. But it's making so little money.
And so basically one has all these goals even beyond the business wants to open an old house for orphans.
So just feeling a little bit like what do I do? How do I get going here with no money?
Right. Okay. I honestly think it's similar to the last question. Right? I know you're along the same lines.
But if you don't know how to add enough value in an industry to start making money, then go learn. Go get taught. Go get a mentor. Go find a job where you can learn that.
Make mistakes. Get paid to make mistakes. And then start, I mean it sounds like he's already doing his thing on the side.
So keep doing that. Keep doing it on the side. Keep hustling. But that combination of things where you're taking a job because you like it, because you're learning.
It may not be your ideal long-term thing of what you want to do, but you're learning the ropes and you're making money and you're making contacts.
And make sure you're spending time every single day hustling for your business.
Absolutely. I remember that we had another fashion designer from India in one of our previous episodes that kind of had a similar struggle.
And I'm going to look for that episode now. But while I'm looking for the next question, I'll hopefully get back to you on that one, Fatima.
All right. Next question is from Kendall. Kendall says, Hi, Evan. I love all your videos, especially the ones on famous movie directors.
All right.
They're really helping out people and you're talking a lot about having passion, having a niche. And my passion is talking about movies.
I want to do a movie review channel. Since it's a crowded space, I wonder if I should focus on a genre or sub-genre of film to talk about and review on my channel.
All right. Cool.
So I love I would love to watch. I don't think I've seen any movie channels out there.
It's not that it's not there. I just haven't come across any. But I actually love movies.
I would want to check out your channel.
But I think, yeah, I think one of the things that I said yesterday was.
How do you see the world differently and how is your perspective different?
Because we talked so much about how you have to differentiate yourself.
And part of I think what taps into that is thinking about how is your perspective different?
Because the way that you watch movies, the way that you see movies is is the one thing that can really differentiate you from everyone else.
So I would just say, Kendall, pay attention to the very subtle nuances of how you see the world differently.
I mean, I'm thinking about your interview with Chase Jarvis, too. He tells his photographers, like, what's that picture that only you can take?
You know, and try to figure what figure out what that is.
And I think everybody has that ability to have that spin on something that is uniquely you.
So that's where I'd start, Kendall.
Every space is crowded.
If you're going after any kind of any market worth going after, you know, there's there's going to be other people there.
Every space is crowded. But there is always room for quality.
Always, you know, if you're a fan of the YouTube channel, you know, I wasn't the first to do this.
I wasn't the first guy on YouTube.
I joined late to the party, but I'm having as big an impact as I can.
And I'm not worried about what the people above me are doing.
There's always room for quality.
And if I was better at what I was doing, then I would I would get more results, too.
You know, I deserve the results that I'm getting right now.
Good and bad. Like, I deserve the good. Like, it may be better than what a lot of people are doing.
And I deserve that for the effort and hard work that I'm putting in.
But I don't have a million subscribers or 10 million subscribers, you know, so I'm not I'm not producing at that level yet.
I'm not good enough to do that yet.
So whatever your movie reviews, there's an opportunity.
Right. There's an opportunity for you to have a lot of success there. You just need to figure out how you can add value.
What's missing from most movie reviews? What's currently missing that most people aren't doing?
And what can you do to fill that void?
That's we need to figure out.
There's always room for quality.
Yeah. Every industry is crowded.
If it's not crowded, then there's not a big opportunity there.
So. Good luck.
OK, so just going back to the last question about the fashion aspiring fashion designer in India,
you may want to also check out episode six or I'm sorry, episode four.
Because there is a another designer in India that actually had some similar questions.
So Evan may have said some things also in that episode that may really help you that we didn't say today.
So check out episode four. Or Rishi may have said something, too.
Hello. Thanks, Evan.
All right. Give us an update on the game. It's looking like it. Game is nuts. Game is intense.
Yeah, it's we're we're I don't know the next teamfight.
I said it last time. We haven't had a big teamfight. So I the team is 51 and 57.
I am 21 and eight. So I need to not die because it's going to be pretty bad for our team if I do.
But pretty much everybody is that, you know, like you can't build any more items.
You're as strong as you're going to get. Oh, I just died. Very sad.
So we'll see. It's going to end soon. We just need we'll see what what happens on the teamfights.
Somebody's going to somebody's going to die and that's going to be the game.
But we could do one more. We've got one more. We could do one more question.
Cool. So we have another fashion designer, actually.
And Julia is asking, I'm a lady with a strong passion for fashion.
I'm 30 years old. I've been designing and selling as a part time job for six years alongside working in telecom.
I starved to buy selling machines. I buy fabric to try new styles for friends just to be encouraged that I can really do this.
I stay awake to sew at dawn and nine hours wasted during the day at the office.
OK, so she's saying she's she's doing everything she can after job hours and feels like nine hours are wasted as she's at her job.
My problem is I have a fear of quitting my job to start my business in fashion.
And I don't even know why I sew well and I don't know how to start or go about it.
Fashion is everything I want to do. I want to be it, not just say it.
I want to be it, not just say it. Cool.
So I like the hunger Julie has. She's just like does everything she can after her job to just make it happen.
But is feeling that fear of just stepping out and fear of leaving her secure job.
Yeah, I it sounds to me like she's already positioning herself to transition well.
She's doing everything she can outside of the job and is, you know, making outfits already for her friends.
And so I guess, Julie, I you don't have to jump out of the ship and go from having a job to absolutely nothing.
What is stopping you from generating income right now?
I don't know if you're just kind of giving your your clothes at this point or if you're actually selling them.
But can you start doing something where you can regularly start generating income for your designs?
And little by little, as you build up, you know, your business, jumping out of the ship of quitting your job won't be so scary.
We just had a crazy fight and we're maybe going to lose. We'll see. I don't know. It's tight.
Yeah, I agree. It's it is scary, you know, but you can make it less scary by not having to go all in.
To Rishi's point, it doesn't have to be something that you just jump off the cliff and quit your job and, you know, you lose all safety and you just go out and do it.
For some people it works, but it doesn't have to it doesn't have to be the path for you.
I would I hate that path. I hate going.
So here's the thing. I love going all in on something once it works.
You know, like when I find something that I that that really, really works well for me, I go all in on it.
Whether that's, you know, a business strategy, a relationship, you know, partnership.
But I do a lot of small testing to get that level of comfort first, and I don't I don't just launch all in hoping that something is going to work out.
So I would test it. I would build my I would try to build my business up to the point where I am making enough to support myself, not make tons of cash, but just support myself.
And then once I did that, I would go all in on whatever my business was.
If I could have a little bit of certainty to pay my bills and pay the Internet and all that stuff, not live a huge life of luxury, but just pay my bills.
If I could do that, then I would then leave whatever job I had to go off and do my thing full time.
So that's how you balance it.
Sounds like you're ready. And it can be frustrating that you're not like that it takes time to go out and actually do.
But that's the plan. I think you can do it. And we just lost Gigi.
Good luck.
Yeah.
All right. That was a heck of a game. That was a long game, man. That was a long game.
Let's see how we did.
I went I went twenty two kills and eight deaths.
I got an S plus.
And our team, everybody else on our team had more deaths than kills.
So that's usually a good recipe for losing.
Anyway, good times. We got some great questions in.
What's the Rishi word of advice to close us out on?
Yeah, I think just cup of cup of risk.
And what I mean by risk is a lot of I think people think that entrepreneurs are like just jumping off of these cliffs and doing crazy things.
But like you said, Evan, you know, you first figure out what is working and you're making you're minimizing risk by thinking smart about it.
So it doesn't have to be one or the other. All or nothing. Just.
Yeah. Take it easy.
Feeling the love, feeling the love. Well, thank you guys so much for watching.
I'm going to get ready for some future live streams coming up today on the channel.
Seven more to go. But if this is the last time I'm seeing you today, have an awesome rest of your Thursday.
Continue to believe or cup or rise or whatever your one word is.
And we'll see you soon.